[Music]
las vegas could be the site of super
bowl 58 how do you greet cristian
home of the informative consumer of news
now in spanish the nfl is expected to
announce this change on tuesday super
158 was planned to be made
new orleans but the  dates coincide
with monica this february allianz stadium
will host the tested
nfl draft will also arrive in las vegas in
april the nevada athletics commission
approved a series of new regulations
for boxing matches considered
exhibition this comes after
nate's death  in valencia the student of an
uvi who collapsed during a fight
carried out beneficiary the draft
exists is the signed this law where it
ensures that such events must
comply with the regulations in the
future and I tell you that the graduates of
an audi are preparing for their great  day
about 2,200 students will listen to
this from 37 states and 45 countries
this tuesday the ceremony
begins at 4 in the afternoon  and in the tau
month the max center from all of
the news now team congratulations and we
close with a look at the
temperatures today we will have a windy day
rain and snow are expected in the mountains it
will be cold with temperatures in the 57
degrees during the day  and tomorrow it will be
partially cloudy with temperatures
just over 50 degrees and with
lows in the 30s I am Cristian Cásseres
with his Spanish Kirchner information plan
good day